the president Donald Trump has awarded
Jerry West the Presidential Medal of
Freedom which is the highest honor a
civilian can get and the great Jerry
West Hall of Famer joins us on the
program good morning Jerry that's a
quite an honor there when did you find
out well I found out I guess last night
and I watch it I got to show you
something funny and here was I guess on
a on a email she'd received and I said I
said you got to be kidding this is a
joke and it was you know and I read it a
sonata she got to be a joke and anyway
all of a sudden I started getting a lot
of Texas from people and who were just
happy that I was recipient of this award
and frankly shocking and almost for the
first time my life and I really don't
know quite how they will accept an award
like this to be honest with you I've
never it's not something I've ever even
though they thought about but I've
looked at some of the people on the
award who have been there and some of
the people who have done some
extraordinary things in sports but more
importantly they made a difference in
the way we look at minorities in this
world and some of them are my great
friends and people that I've admired for
years and to be in that being that class
I'm really thrilled well as humble as
you are when I first read this I went oh
gosh I can only imagine like how
uncomfortable this might make you feel
well honestly you know I I've been under
the weather a little bit of that like a
kind of case of flu here and been out
very much I'm almost afraid to go out to
see some of my friends because I want to
disregard it and I don't want to really
talk about it but to say I guess it's a
bigger deal than I've ever thought about
and I think specially growing up in West
Virginia which honestly Dan I attributed
awful lot of this stuff to SAP in my
life from going up there the things I
saw living a tough life and
having to do things by yourself with
little or no encouragement I just think
it's the way of life or West Virginia
people that who's perfect persevered in
some respects and just pretty amazing to
be just be where I am at this point in
my life it's just amazed been an amazing
journey and I looked at some of the
other men who have won this and you got
Jackie Robinson you got Jesse Owens you
got Muhammad Ali pretty pretty John
Wooden's on there some pretty big names
well really amazing and I see so many of
these people you know Bill Russell who
I've always had the greatest admiration
for some of these people were were more
than athletes
they were voices more minorities and
then I read a lot and you know I care to
read about American history and people
who have made a real difference in
particularly in the civil rights areas
and there's some people on there who
basically almost risked their careers
and for for speaking out and I admire
those people so much I wish that in some
respect that I've had that voice when I
was younger even though I was really shy
and wouldn't know how to do it to be
honest with you but they're just so many
people I admire on that list you talked
about growing up in West Virginia the
book that you wrote written about you
know what you grew up the circumstances
and relationship with your father or
lack thereof and you know sleeping with
a gun under your bed and like I don't
know if all of that comes back through
you know it's through you and you just
like does it hit you that way that you
just look back and say how did I get
here and here I am going to the White
House to receive this honor well Dan is
in many respects and you know something
things to choose you in life and you
never know why and I think for any young
kid out there who's kind of has a
solitary life other kids don't like
doing things that you like and you pick
up something and you become it really
becomes your best friend and more
importantly you a lot of people I think
Joan Didion said
she said people tell themselves stories
in order to live and I did and you know
I could go out there and play basketball
by myself
I could be the coach the referee I could
always walk away from there it makes a
winning shot and and then you never knew
what you were going to see when you went
home and that that was my way of feeling
good and then obviously I never even
dreamed that I would grow tall enough
and you know had a massive growth spurt
when I was in high school and didn't
have a lot of offers and suddenly my
senior year I started to attract a lot
an awful lot of attention and really I
could have pretty much gone to any
school I wanted to Ivy League schools in
school but school including by the way
and I've never looked at myself as a
scholar I've just looked at myself as
someone who's curious about a lot of
things love to read and love to engage
myself and things that I would never
expose to before and then playing at
West Virginia a university and getting
drafted second player in the draft not
even think I was good enough to even get
there and then moving to Los Angeles
first team out here and you know so many
years involved here with Lakers of the
players 14 a lot of terrible
disappointing times losing in the finals
all of those things make you stronger
and it makes you more determined and
I've always felt that you know people
are always talking about people's
mentality to me the people that a little
bit quieter I like their mentality
better the ones who who out there trying
to show it all the time sometimes I
think it's false and that wasn't wasn't
me I just love the competition love to
try to try to win but the thing that
made it best with the people I met along
the way the players all the fans who
have been so kind to me over the years
here in Los Angeles and the late Mike
Hisey at Memphis who hired me there and
the Weir's being part of that group now
with the bar with Steve Ballmer here in
Los Angeles those have been really
special times and to be kind of relevant
to
at 81 years of age it's even more
important to me you almost said 80 years
of age you were trying to leave out that
laters no no I didn't want to leave it
out I just had a birthday a few days ago
I would never do that
I'm not one I'm not exactly 40 anymore
dan I know you are but when's the last
time you shot hoops oh my gosh a long
time ago I think it was a warrior they
were having some kind of a little thing
up there a few years ago and I just I
think I made about 13 in a row dan it's
not something I could do i watch the
players play today and our mom a lot of
things that they do I do think a game
has changed immensely and you heard you
talking about a different kind of
defense well that's exactly what what
makes it fun coaches that devise things
to make other people get out of their
comfort zone and and today's day in
today's day and day in MVA you know it's
a it's kind of a prettier game because
there's not a lot of fouls called you
know people you jump sideways you jump
straight into people it the fouls are
not called the same way they're really
not and the game is prettier and more
importantly I think it's for the fans
the players are truly professional
because they can work on their craft all
year long with enormous amount of money
they're talking they're making now and
going to make more in the future players
making fifty million dollars a year
that's it's it's almost incomprehensible
and for a lot of people and as long as
they respect a game and play hard every
night and I could care less what they
make I just like to watch the game and
particularly incredibly skilled players
we have today and with the rules that
makes it even better but it's kind of
awkward to even talk about it I'm afraid
you even can t mention teams anymore I
know I'm just going to ask you though
Jerry that got fined $50,000 for just
complimenting Kawhi Leonard well you
know as I say there's a lot of players
are greatly admire I really do but it's
a slippery slope
there and I think Dan there is a to set
two rules you know when you're in
college and people want you to go to
school you get recruited well active
players can do anything they want to
today and that's acceptable you say I'm
going to recruit this guy when recruit
that guy well I don't think any player
could ever recruit me never I would want
to play where I thought the situation
was better for me that maybe it's
someplace I'd always wanted to consider
but free agency is difficult and I think
it's really terrible when some of these
great players are mentioned while the
playoffs are going on by and
particularly by players coaches how do
you promote the game I don't mean oh
there's so many players I'd like to say
nice things about a greatly admire and
you really appreciate how they play you
just you're almost afraid to promote the
game that you love where would you be
without basketball oh I would have been
dead long ago
I'm sure boy well you know something I
have a Restless mind okay I can't
imagine myself working for a coal mine I
just can't do it I can't imagine myself
I would have never been able to go to
college and I do believe that men should
not I should be should be busy and not
idle and I every this every once in a
while you know I think not for myself my
said oh my gosh what if this hadn't
happened this particular little
incidents in my life just a little small
thing and I said what if that never
happened
I would be I don't know I would I would
be just be a person who try to be nice
to everyone try to be helpful and more
importantly try to encourage young kids
I think when you go up differently one
of the things you want to do is
encourage people and even to this day I
try to help everyone nb8 I think is it
comes to me or calls me about particular
jobs or something I will make a phone
call for them and if I believe them I
really will and when you when you
sometimes you don't realize that maybe
you have a little
bit different kind of impact on people
and I love people and I particularly
love the game of basketball which has
given me so much people that I most
admire are the people that competed
against and particularly the people I
played with you know I've worked for
some incredible people Jerry Buss who
gave me a chance here in Los Angeles as
a to work isn't exactly a little did I
know what I would ever do when I retired
from basketball and then late Mike
Heisley the Warriors whole group up
there a real special group of people and
I'd like to talk about some of their
players but they're people I consider
friends and you know just how special
they are and now here with the Clippers
Steve Ballmer just frankly an amazing
man and he's really kind of rejuvenated
me working with Lawrence Franks and Doc
Rivers and kind of great staff there and
my ears with the Lakers will be the
highlight of my life that's for sure
well Congrats it's wonderful and you
know proud to know you you didn't have
to get this for me to say I'm proud to
know you but it's it's a wonderful honor
and hopefully you'll you'll be
comfortable receiving that well I thank
you Dan and one of the things I would
always say about you is that people ask
me constantly some wonderful people who
are broadcasters and their shows and
everything really really nice people to
listen there's no one better than yours
and Isis they come you're incredibly
gifted and people people listen to you I
know they're big fans and I wish you
continued success and more importantly
continue good health
Thank You Jerry and we'll be keeping an
eye on this and be careful don't say
nice things about anybody in the NBA
okay well I'll say not something that
acts about information maybe he'll give
Thank You Jerry Thank You Jerry West is
receiving the Presidential Medal of
Freedom and I wondered about this the
first thing I thought of when I saw that
he had won was what is his reaction
going to be and the second part was I
couldn't I
can't fathom what it must have been like
to be I believe twelve years of age and
he put a shotgun underneath his mattress
because if his father did anything to
his mother again that he was going to
kill him and you know he he told that
story to us and said it almost in a
matter-of-fact way that hey I was not
gonna let my dad put his hands on my mom
again so you know we see the finished
product but Jerry West has come a long
long way and just turned 81 and I hope
he lives a long long time but that's
great honor the Presidential Medal of
Freedom for more Dan Patrick show tune
in the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]